hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website common today we're in
round nine of our coverage of the 2016
candidates tournament winner of this
tournament does go on to face Magnus
Carlsen in November for the World
Championship our competitors today two
of the leaders visi Nam playing the
white pieces reigning champion of the
candidates tournament and Aleman Aronian
playing the black pieces LeMond is in
the lead co-leader with Sergey Karjakin
and vision on half a points behind them
a win for either of these players would
be huge certainty cardiac and tide today
so a win would put Vichy and on tied for
the leaders in Levon Aronian he were to
win that would put him in sole
possession of first place both these
players been in playing extremely well
Levon Aronian in my opinion playing the
best in the tournament so far so without
further ado we'll go ahead and get
started
pani for always exciting to see the
chignon play pani 4 before this
tournament I can't remember a time where
he was playing pani for this regularly
but maybe in his head he's already just
thinking that he's gonna be played
magnus carlsen so just getting ready for
just tons of e4 it figure might as well
play it himself but pani for pani 5 9 f3
knight c6 I think we all kind of
expected the right Lopes getting into
the Berlin defense because that's what
we see every single round but instead we
see something different we see the
Italian game we see Bishop here to c4
and Levon Aronian responds with Bishop
to c5 the quiet game generally said the
quiet game because there's not too many
fireworks that happen in a match that
kind of starts like this now this she
responds with castle on the kingside and
sometimes you may see Knight f6 pun d4
this is the max Lynch gambit this is a
pretty crazy gambit if you haven't seen
it there is a video on the website
business website calm you can kind of
check that out they did not opt for this
instead after your castle on the Kings
side we see pawn d6 pawn d3 which is
probably one of the more quieter ways
you can actually play the quiet game so
neither side so far makes it seem like
they want to make a big splash usually
when you're pulling someone near the top
of the table
it's just not worth trying to
for glory when you could just get a draw
they definitely don't want to lose in
this position so they continue Knight f6
pawn to c3 potentially looking for a
pond to a d4 opening up the center of
the board pond a6 pawn a4 and then
Bishop back here to a7 controlling these
diagonals is very important this light
square bishop here on c4 starts to
attack the square here on f7 which right
now is kind of the least defended square
for black early on since the king is the
only piece that kind of holds onto it
after castle that does change opposite
side of the board this dark square
bishop attacks to this pawn here on f2
so both of these bishops the light
square for white the dark square fer for
black are definitely the most powerful
in the Italian game so it decides to
bring it back here to a7 it's gonna be
attacking this long diagonal for the
foreseeable future
Knight to a3 there's no great squares
for this night to come to it could come
to d2 and very easily you know block
this c1 bishop but once it moves again
it's no longer blocked but usually when
it comes to c4 can't really come to c4
in this situation so instead machine ons
decide to go and bring it to a3 bishop
or Knight back here to e7 now Knight c2
can start to see him or rearranging his
pieces a little bit Knights g6 so kind
of move this one from a c6 towards the
King side of the board if I come back a
little bit if we look at variations
instead of knight c6 I almost prefer
just castling on the King side seeing
what Vichy and on comes back with see me
if he has anything crazy to do here but
I like this night here on c6 it seems
like it's doing a good job but Levon
Aronian decided that wasn't worth it
decided to go and bring it back here to
e7
and then after Knight c2 then brings it
to g6 a Bishop to e3 so I really like
this approach from Vichy and Ani says
hey your most powerful bishop right now
is your dark square Bishop my dark
square bishop doesn't really do too much
in the Italian game especially early on
so I'm gonna go ahead and exchange
that off the board so after castle on
the kingside we do see the exchange on
board so but she does have the better
bishop right here later on if we want to
see an exchange on board we could see
that rook here to e8 Bishop here to e6
or even just queen east 7 Bishop e6
trying to exchange off those lights here
bishop that sounds like a logical plan
for Levon Aronian this she continues
night to e3 Knights g4 attacking the
knight Queen d2 protecting the knight
pawn a5 just extending a little bit on
the Queen side making sure that pawn a5
does not happen for Vietnam pond d4
looking to blow up the center of the
board rook back to a8 then we start to
see some exchange on board so e5 Knight
recaptures not recaptures Knight here to
e5 and then Bishop back to b3 does not
want to exchange that material off he
really does like his bishop right here
and then Knight to d7 and there's a few
options that vision on has right now my
favorite option is to be very aggressive
so in my own games this is kind of how I
approach it I know my opponents are
going to be very different than Levon
Aronian so take that and keep that in
mind as I go over this but I think f4 is
a really great way to start to attack
any time my opponent retreats a little
bit so Knight to d7 blocking off his
lights where a bishop you can see his
pieces are kind of in retreat mode rook
here on F fates not doing too much rook
on a8 really can't get too involved we
kind of just saw it retreat back already
the Queen's really the only piece that's
doing too much right now as far as being
able to get involved too very very
quickly so pawn to f4 starts to
immediately put pressure on the King
side my bishop is already pointed at the
Kings side I can get my Knights quickly
involved in any sort of attacking this
rook right here allows me to start to
push forward now from here we can see
rook e8 and that's just threatening this
material right here on e4 but I can just
be pretty aggressive Queen to d5 this is
threatening mates right here you really
need to stop a mating threat so
weenie seven then look here to e1 so I
can probably see the Queen can't just
come here to e4 because that would be
Czech mates in a few moves right there
so all in all I think this is a really
good way to approach it there's not a
lot of great moves that Levon Aronian
has to kind of protect against this and
say we see a safer move we see Bishop
here - see - I'm just getting ready to
push his beep on a little bit forward so
after Bishop b2 then rookie eights and
then upon f3 just solidifying the pawn
chain a little bit not as fun but
definitely a solid play all and all pawn
b6 let him find that pawn chain as well
and then rook over here to a d1 if you
kind of look at and say could he just
bring his rook over here he could but
it's one of those where you play your
rook to d1 it was protecting the pawn
here on a4 and then your opponent plays
Knight to c5 attacking that pawn on a4
and you kind of ask for your move to be
taken back because you really just wish
you'd moved your other rook over there
so vision on decided let's just go ahead
and not take the move back let's play
rook here to a d1 and then Knight to c5
followed by pawn to b4 and then we see
the quick retreat of the night right
back here to d7 which seems somewhat odd
to me almost knowing the opponent's
gonna be playing pawn to b4 to kind of
waste a move right here but Levon
Aronian up into this point seems
somewhat lost definitely the most I've
seen him in this tournament so far he's
kind of dominated pretty much all his
opponents even when he drew a couple of
them and some of the postgame matches he
found some winning combinations that
actually would have checkmated his
opponent so he's at almost a higher
level thinking up into this tournament
but he seems just bamboozled by the
Italian game Vichy and on seems to be in
complete control although it has been
kind of a quiet game that nothing too
crazy has happened the bottom Ryan seems
unsure how to defend correctly and so
all of his pieces are kind of just all
right in the center of the board he's
just kind of waiting for vision not to
make
kamu and then just try to defend without
making any huge mistakes this she
continues Bishop b3 he does still like
this long diagonal but as we talked
about he didn't want to get that pawn a
little bit forward pawn to b4 now Knight
f6 opening up the door for the light
square bishop you get involved Queen a
d4 just threatening the center of the
board always good to have a very very
forward Queen towards the middle and
late game nights at d5 attacking the
Queen we do see an exchange on board now
this Bishop on d5 this is not a little
outpost the rook is forced to move rook
here a7 and then pawn to b5 this game
space for white this is really solid we
do have another outpost we can come up
here to c6 even start to take away some
of the back of rank moves that black hat
so all of these options really good
bishop b7 pawn to c4 and then queenie v
if you kind of look at and say well you
know why wouldn't live on Aronian just
go ahead and take right here it gets
kind of awkward after the pawn
recaptures you do have a semi-open file
right here on the c file and wishing I
could just put all of his material just
attacking this backward pawn right here
on c7 and the bottom Rodya just has to
spend most of his time just defending
this pawn he doesn't have any great
options himself as far as what he should
be attacking so all in all this is a
pretty tough position for black to deal
with so he doesn't do that and Cindy
decides to go ahead and come down here
Queen to e5 rook to c1 and then we do
see an exchange on board and then both
sides decide okay now it's time to go
ahead and start getting our kings
activated into the game so King f8 King
f2 King e7 pawn pushing forward to f4
King f6 rook c3 now we'll send the rook
to h3 starting to attack on the King
side of the board pawn h6 rook g3
attacking a pawn right here and then
rookie 7 defending and then rook very
aggressively playing rook to g6
attacking all of these pawns right here
so he could take the pawn depending on
where the rookie
check and then both of these would be
isolated ponds he can gobble those up
very very quickly so definitely if you
kind of look at this I would say machine
on has a better position on board Levon
Aronian decided to go ahead and now take
with his Bishop here on d5 and then as
you can imagine you know how we would
recapture we're going to recapture with
that pawn not nearly as good to capture
with our rook right here or pawn would
be even worse just to go ahead and AB
this open file available for black to
kind of control
instead pawn to d5 this is kind of what
we're talking about before opens up the
door to really attack this backward pawn
here on c7 any time you can attack upon
you you want it to be back here all on
the seventh rank because that's where
you're gonna be putting your rooks
anyway so that's fishy and ons plan
right now rook a8
King f3 we do see a double rook here so
both the roofs attack in his pawn right
here this chignon has two options he can
try to hold on to this pawn he does have
his rook in his King holding on to this
so playing pawn to g4 this is the
approach I probably would have gone with
just to see what my opponent does right
here you can really start to put a lot
of pressure on the King side
Bishan on decided let's just get crazy
here let's play King to g4 let's allow
my opponents to go ahead and take
material and then rook g7 kind of been
in between move check forcing the King
to move and then a rook down here to d2
King over here b8 rook to c2 and you can
start to see what machine ons been
working towards this entire time both of
his rooks here attacking this pawn here
on c7 out Lebon Aronian rook to c8 but
now black is kind of in that I'm now
defending mode instead of just attacking
with both of his rooks
white now continues rook a to wants to
make sure you holds on to that pawn on a
four rook d4 attacking the pawn on d5
then machine on decide to play King f5
if you're gonna hey if you're gonna take
my pawn here on d5 I'm gonna start to
gobble up some of your material
rook takes on d5 and then a king takes
on f6 so both sides have a passed pawn
White has a passed pawn on the F file
and black has a passed pawn on the D
file so both sides are gonna be rushing
to make sure that they can get a passed
pawn as far up the board as possible and
just put a threat on board rook f8
attacking the King we do see an exchange
on board and then rook to f5 check then
you can start to gobble up that material
so small win right there for black and
then pawn to g3 so this is a very
important note a lot of people make a
mistake they would say okay you take my
pawn I'm just gonna recapture here on h6
make sure we're even in material and
then I have to pass pawns over here you
have one pass pawn let's just race it
out but this would be a huge mistake
because rook h4 that's Czech and you're
gonna end up losing material on h2 but
if you instead look a little bit more
and say pawn g3 this does stop of the
rook from coming here to h4 so very nice
calculated move from Vichy and on pawn
g3 rook back here to c4 which I'm not
really sure what's the move to c4 does
protects the backward pawn here on c7
that's not really doing anything at all
so I'm not really sure I'm not really
sure Levon Aronian knows exactly what
he's doing with this move it seems
somewhat awkward to me but do you see
the king take here on h6 and when we
start to see the push forward so pawn
here to d5 King h5 pawn d4 pawn g4 pond
e3 pawn appear h4 and then rook to d4
the best way to stop a pushed pawn a
passed pawn specifically is just to get
in front of it so rook here to d2 that
stops all the shenanigans there's no way
for black to really deal with this as
soon as the rook moves off this file to
maybe come down here and try something
crazy the rook can just take this and so
black just kind of has to waiting to see
what Vichy and on des he's gonna need to
get his King involved because right
I just does not have the material he
needs to do anything further so King a
c8 pawn g5 and now vision on starts to
attack King D 7 King do six and then
rook takes on h4 and this is another one
of those where I I just don't know that
this is the best way to go he decides to
go and give up his only pawn as we said
before and he allows fishing on to have
a pushed pawn a passed pawn here on the
G file that he can push forward and
although they are even in material black
really can't be doing too much with his
pawns over here on the Queen side and so
he's just now in complete defense mode
but this is a pretty tough defense he
doesn't have his King and his rook
connected at all and so this rook here
can kind of just block off getting the
King involved it can come to f3 can come
to III and all of a sudden the King
can't move it's just this king over here
and that's gonna be very tough to stop
this attack by busy and on so King eh we
first see the Brooke over here a3 just
stopping the attack on a4 then rook over
here c4 King g7 getting ready to push
forward King d7 push forward g6
pawn c6 trying to last bit of hope on
the Queen side recognizing that he
couldn't do too much over here on the
King side King f6 pawn recapture or pawn
takes pawn pushes forward g7 rook over
here g4 pawn takes rook down here g1
look at the three check and then we see
rookie three check King d7 rook up here
e5 and then the rook captures here on a
g7 there's just no way to stop the pond
pushing forward anymore so Levon Aronian
asides to go ahead and take right here
efficient on decides I can go ahead and
take here that's fine as well but just
to add salt to the wound I'm not even
gonna take your rook I'm gonna play rook
here to d4 check and then after this he
can decide to go ahead and
but Levon Aronian had had enough he
decides to go ahead in this position to
go ahead and resign so congratulations
to this she and on he is now tied for
first in the tournament I just really
did not expect him to play so well but
we've said it before he prepares better
than anyone for a tournament it
definitely seemed like he had a game
plan where caught his opponent off guard
not sure if he had kind of a scattering
reporting on Levon Aronian that he just
didn't know how to play certain lines in
the Italian game maybe as well as some
of the other lines that he's seen him
play but he played this to perfection I
think he played one of the best in games
I've seen in a while it's definitely a
double rook in game he just played it
perfectly calculated everything
perfectly Levon Aronian
I don't think he made any massive
mistakes I just think overall he had
slight moves here and there that maybe
could have been improved I don't know if
he always knew the best place for that
he should have been going to defend
correctly I never felt like he had an
attack where machine on was under any
sort of threat and in the end that kind
of cost him I know he was trying to hold
on for a draw as long as possible so he
has kind of dipped back a little bit he
did not gain any points so he's now half
a point behind he and vision on kind of
just switched places in the standings so
again congratulations fishing on we do
have a off day tomorrow for so round 10
will start again back up in two days but
thank you for everyone for watching the
coverage so far we do have five rounds
left so a lot of chest still to be
played but thank you again and I'll see
you guys in the next round